jack yes you saw what the prob boys were
doing in dc in dc
last weekend looked a whole lot like
antifa to me oh
so we're going to start off like that
are we trying from our way so
i'm not a proud boy and i'm not a proud
here to carry any water for them
whatsoever but i saw them talk about it
i saw them tearing down banners
yeah lighting them on fire yeah and i've
seen antifa stealing flags and letting
them on fire yeah and i don't i think
stealing someone's private property and
destroying it is wrong
okay i think if you want if you want to
have a symbol of your political belief
you're allowed to do it we have to
respect these boundaries
uh i agree with almost everything of
what you said there
except for the last one but hold on the
point of this is not for me to rag on
the proud boys
this is actually me defending the proud
boys okay when they do
which is not even as bad as antifa
because antifa attacks
innocent regular people and threatens
innocent regular people
now it was wrong because the the
churches that the proud boy the banners
off of were innocent
but it's not it's not to the same scale
of antifa
you know chasing people down the street
and beating them the proud boys are
facing hate crime charges hate crime
charges
possible possible and and wasn't it the
proud boys who got they were the ones
who got stabbed
proud boys got stabbed yeah critical
condition three of them got stabbed in
an altercation
it's unclear as to who was uh who
provoked
the uh authentication in the first and
the daily mail admitted
the knife from the photo right they
should totally cover
it up so so listen here's the first
point i want to make starting this off
and then we'll carry on
the reason i bring this up in the
context of our previous conversation yes
sir
auntie [ __ ] go around and doing it
for years yes the proud boys go and do
something not even
to the same degree but similar and
immediately
the cops are like hate crime
investigation we're taking these guys
down
okay so i have guys on the inside of mpd
we've been talking about this they've
been talking to me i've been on this
story thinking about it
and first things first is if you burn
a black lives matter banner that's not a
crime
right if you print up a sign that looks
exactly like all the other signs
and you take it out in the street and
you burn it no problem if you find a
black lives matter banner on the ground
and you pick it up and you burn it
no problem if you
if you happen to be in possession of it
and you burn it no problem the only time
that it's a problem
is if you if you if you steal it right
and so i don't know that there was they
don't have any
uh direct video evidence maybe they
weren't actually saying that there was
confirmed theft first so theft needs to
come before destruction of
private property and then you have to
have like hateful intent and bias and
whatever so
what happens is they they saw the crime
of the burning they wanted to prosecute
it it goes to
the twitter handle it's the the police
twitter handle is the one that decides
how to characterize it
so i'm sure that's a political decision
right and then once it's characterized
as a hater bias crime then it goes to
some sort of liaison unit
whose job it is for them to go and
investigate and i have a feeling it will
get lost
somewhere in there first of all they
haven't been able to confirm or convict
that they were theft
in the first place and it's totally
perfectly legal to take a black lives
matter banner
burn it whatever now so a lot of a lot
of these guys that were surrounding it
there's no crime for them because as far
as they knew someone had a banner and
they burned it correct yeah
correct the only time it would be a
crime is if somebody was witnessed and
saw them it was confirmed that they
stole it from another
even though it has the church's logo on
it they if they found it on the street
and burned it still not a crime yeah
uh but the interesting thing is you're
right about the hate crime it's like
political black lives matter is such an
exquisitely crafted phrase
that it is at once a a political
movement it's at once
a statement of some sort fact and it's
at once something that tugs on your
heart strings about being racist or not
but the truth is it means different
things to different people
when the church puts it up on their i'm
sure they really mean like black lives
matter we should just
let's not have black people it's a
church yeah it's a church that doesn't
that doesn't mean that they're going to
be acting in the right way all the time
of course any religious organization
that's not justification for them uh but
it is clearly a political movement
right it's clearly and like has has
funding with billions of dollars and
they have initiatives and they have a
platform ten point
six billion ten point six billion
dollars and and the juicy delicious part
is watching the blm groups
fight about that money there's 10.6
billion
there's a schism in the blm chapters
with the national and whatever
they're fighting over the money but you
know and it's just cracks me up to see
them just going down the normal route
but it's not a hate crime to burn a
donkey
or an elephant or even the flag the
reason i bring this up
is for one yes i want to be critical of
what the proud boys did to a certain
degree
but also defend them in this in in the
sense that if
the da's allowed us the media allows
this for antifa
then how could they come out with this
double standard it just shows you
the media clearly doesn't represent the
people it's
it's all ideological and that brings me
back to some of the earlier stuff we
were talking about
the election the numbers none of it
matters it just matters what people
choose to believe and what to fight for
so when when i look at
these uh uh i'll just put i'll be more
general so i don't single anybody out
there are too many instances where
conservatives
were say defying lockdown and getting
arrested
and they were complying and not
resisting and there are too many
instances where the left
literally beat the cops and then get
their charges dropped
yeah that's how extreme the disparity is
between the left and the right yeah that
antifa for this whole year
you know the chaz this is amazing i
learned this today you know chad was
never cleared out
we thought the the the the capitol hill
autonomous zone was gone right
no they stayed in the cal anderson park
until now
with tents with barricades and
everything i did not know that
nobody cared because the city said we
got rid of it
and the main area the streets were
opened up but the park itself remained
occupied
by these far leftists and i just sort of
disappeared that was going on forever
and in the meantime we've had many
stories of people defying lockdown
and the nypd shows up and arrests them
how incredible is that
at the far left can riot they can they
can destroy things they can
i'll tell you this we got a story where
a guy uh has a business it's called
rio's ribs
and the neighboring building was burnt
down it caused damage to like the
greater structure i guess or to the
neighboring buildings
and so he gave an interview where he was
disparaging the writers
so the next day on surveillance on
security food you can watch this they
released the video
just the other day a guy burns the man's
business to the ground
don't you dare speak up against us says
this lunatic and so they threw
burning trash and then he opens the gate
to go back in and look and make sure the
fire's catching
and that's what happens with the far
left and then what do we see the
district attorneys in these places
cut them loose well okay you know what
that's why i'm at the point where i'm
like
i don't care about your city the
arsonist face was blurred
yeah yeah in the in the actual news i'm
like who are they protecting like are
they trying to catch this person
do they want to know who actually did
this who's actually burning down
people's buildings for political reasons
in these places the far left is
protected they can literally burn it
down and the media is like cover their
face because we don't want to get and
then we have to understand
george soros is financing a lot of these
attorney generals and going into local
towns and smaller cities and saying you
know what we're going to give millions
of
dollars let's be specific the what is it
called the open society foundation
yeah that provides grants to nonprofits
who then
fund and they've financed a lot of
different ones that are creating and
sewing havoc
in big cities like san francisco the the
san francisco attorney general is now
the los angeles attorney general
and that's why a lot of people are
saying what we saw in san francisco with
that entire mess i remember
even a few months ago walking down the
street in san francisco covering the
utter madness
i was doing a random walk and talk video
and i literally saw a woman screaming
police officers hearing it and walking
the other direction there was
crap i watched that lady yeah i watched
the lady
walk into the middle of the street and
she was like big fat lady and just
dropped trout right there in the middle
of the street just go at it
and i was like whoa dude yeah i wasn't
even looking for it i was literally at
the capitol
and you just see a whole bunch of people
all around it shooting up
urinating crapping and and just totally
out of it
it seems like a zombie world out there
and this is because of these attorney
generals
now los angeles as the same attorney
general as they did in san francisco
same guy supported by soros and a lot of
people are expecting the same thing to
happen as he's making
these similar kind of protocols let's
try these ideas together real quick
when i see antifa now start acting a
fool
targeting innocent businesses i'll be
mad
but if i see far leftists setting up
tonight zones don't care
because i see these cops abusing regular
people and
attacking the innocent not all cops but
these place in these places
and i'll tell you this there's uh uh
there's a meme that goes around from the
left they say it's really funny
if you have 1300 good cops and 12
you have 1312 cops 1300 are really good
people
who stand by the law in the constitution
but 12 of them are criminals who keep
breaking the law
and that 1300 doesn't say anything to
stop the criminals
then you have 1 312 bad cops that's the
mean you know why
one three one two a-cab all cops are bad
uh
i don't know i don't agree with that but
in new york city specifically
if these cops know it's happening and
they keep doing that job
without protest without standing up to
defend the people of that city
then i think they're just they're not
cops it's the praetorian guard for the
emperor
for the empire state that's cuomo cuomo
is passing edict he sits there and he
goes i can do whatever i want
churches gone symbols i don't like gone
decision goes against them irrelevant
i'll just make a new one and the cops go
hey we don't care what skoda says we
don't care what the constitution says
we just want that sweet sweet scrilla
from our emperor i think
i think that i agree with that i think i
agree with the 1312 thing not
to put it that way but i think that if
you have 1300 cops who are watching 12
cops do bad things and do nothing to
stop it
what do you have to say for the other
1300 cops why are you not stepping in
why are you not speaking up you see
what's happening and you do nothing
like what what kind of mindset is in
these police departments that they think
it's okay that they just let this
happen let's break it down you know to
get more to the heart of the principle
when i see black lives matter
complaining about innocent people dying
completely sympathize i empathize i
don't like that that's a violation of
every constitutional right to take
someone's life but in many of these
circumstances
they're it's unclear it's it's not
clear-cut that the cop was just like
i'm going to kill this man a lot of it a
lot of times it's like a very serious
conflict and we have a political debate
we want to know what's going to happen
george floyd most of us who came out
when that story came out we were like
dude that's wrong we don't like what we
saw
and then later we learned a bunch of new
details and you're like ah see things
change
but it's pretty clear-cut when a cop
dresses up in civilian clothes and then
arrests
a restaurateur during an economic crisis
where people are going homeless where
they're expecting hundreds of millions
to starve
and the cops are just stomping people
into the ground
that is clear-cut no political debate
and there's record homelessness now in
new york city and there was an article
highlighting some of the pictures of
people living on the streets if you want
to talk about
unsanitary health conditions that's it
right there there's people with scabs
and scavies and all these kind of
horrible illnesses because they have
nowhere else to go
that are literally i mean all the all
the housing that they provide for them a
lot of it is filled up
there's an argument that some people
make that the homeless people don't want
to go to some of these housing but
the housing is getting filled up because
of the horrible economic situation that
has
been created by the government here's we
know the best part about all this
in seattle uh in washington and in
oregon where they're having these
lockdowns like many other places
and the police are enforcing it well
look the cdc said
right the cdc was like you gotta lock
down okay the cdc
also said homeless encampments must
remain it's safer to let them stay
than to clear them out at the same time
that the police are saying
we gotta follow the cdc orders and shut
down your business
sorry they're turning around and
clearing out homeless encampments in
defiance of the cdc
you can't have it both ways either
you're enforcing the safety of the
people
because of the pandemic or you're just
crushing the weak
i think this is a good time for me to
pitch a movie that i'm in coming up the
lauren
southern movie crossfire covers all of
these issues
in depthly and it's very even-handed and
fair and honest and it really takes
a good hard look at the perspective of
the police officers
the black lives matter folks it goes in
depth on antifa
it really does discuss some of these
contradictions and where do your
loyalties lie and what's it like
you know being a guy that does good most
of the time but then witnesses something
that is illegal or wrong
it's very well done there's a lot of
good people in it elijah
schaefer is in it and mike cernovich and
jack and a few others
it's well worth the the the view you
should check it out
wasn't there like an excerpt talking
about the dangers of being a police
officer
but isn't there like a statistic that as
far as as far as employment police
officers are ranked
what is it 13th or i think even lower on
the
on the ranking of of deadliest jobs but
but i disagree with that
you know because you got to understand
the difference in the danger from being
like a petroleum engineer and being a
cop
a petroleum engineer it's like you do
everything right and sometimes there's a
faulty error and something blows and
then you get knocked into the ocean or
whatever
being a cop it's like you're ever you
don't know which person is gonna be the
person who's scared
and wants to flee or is a warrant so
they're gonna pull a gun well i'm not
i'm not making you know that kind of
argument that it's you know totally a
safe and wonderful amazing job
as a police officer we have to
understand the other side of it because
they are dealing with the worst elements
of our society and if you're around that
every day that's going to affect your
psyche
and that's why with most police officers
we see a higher rate of spousal abuse
and also substance abuse than we do with
any other profession out there since of
course
i think there is something to say about
people being affected by their
environment
correlation correlation correlation it
could be that people who are prone to
drug abuse and spousal abuse
like to take risks like adrenaline like
being violent
so they end up being cops you don't know
you don't know but i will say
that you're right you're out there the
movie does address this very issue talks
about ptsd among the police
so uh what you're saying is that all
cops are drug addicts
and i said civil war let's go
yeah but it's really worth it because it
really scooted downy uh also
and john detroit who worked on um uh
hoax the with mike cernovich
they did the direction in the producing
it's fantastic and really well thought
out so check it out
crossfire thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you